I would like to ask all of you for a
special prayer
for Pope Emeritus Benedict who
is silently supporting the church to
remember him he is very ill asking the
lord and console him and support him in
this testimony of love for the
church until the end
[Applause]
replacedon of Benedict
Times the  hope Francis tall The best of
consoning institution in Health
situation in Black
and when I entered the seminary I also
entered a bit on the wave of his
teachings so
I already remember him daily in my prayer these
days even more on the invitation of the
Holy Father  I was not able to clearly see
what he did to Paolo because he
was still small but he is certainly
a good person, he also felt
very bad and it is also right to
pray for him I do not see anything
wrong with it, he is a good person who
did  so much for the church and therefore it is
right to pray for him too because
in any case in a difficult situation
and we must s  always ask him a
prayer
Well pray that he can then
[Music]
get better and not suffer from the disease
that he
doesn't go away so much pain because it hurts
I had a mother I lost a little while ago